[Musique]
déjà l'image du parti et pas très bonne
dans la mesure où l'ump n'a pas été
capable de garder le pouvoir de garder
l'elysée ensuite ils perdent
législatives
donc il ya forcément une remise en
question nicolas sarkozy et partie
a priori il est parti pour de bon et
donc il faut remplir ce vide là ça se
joue avec l'élection à la tête de l'ump
qui est prévue pour le mois de novembre
2012 et qui oppose jean françois copé
président du parti sortant françois
fillon à droite
normalement il ya un chef et donc
forcément à partir du nom nicolas
sarkozy s'en va élus et militants se
disent bon bah qui prend la suite
[Musique]
battu par françois hollande à la
présidentielle de 2012 nicolas sarkozy
se retire de la vie politique et laisse
une droite sans chef pour prendre sa
suite deux hommes vont entamer une
guerre sans merci
l'ancien premier ministre françois
fillon et le dernier secrétaire général
de l'ump jean françois copé françois
fillon semble avoir un net avantage mais
commet l'erreur de formuler des
critiques à l'égard de nicolas sarkozy
alors qu'il est son premier ministre
sortant il se trompe de campagne il fait
une campagne médiatique
là où en fait il faut aller parler aux
militants et que jean-françois copé lui
a bien compris le sens de l'élection et
il fait des déplacements sur le terrain
en s'adressant aux militants
c'est très partagés à l'époque c'est à
dire que autant avant on avait
l'impression que les militants étaient
100 % sarkozyste et puis 10 avec le
départ de nicolas sarkozy ils sont un
peu divisé donc il ya ceux qui aiment
françois fillon et notamment chez les
élus et il ya ceux qui aiment jean
françois copé qui est quand même très
populaire chez les militants parce que
justement ils l'ont vu beaucoup ils
l'entendent long cours et il va au
combat donc ça les militants apprécient
la difficulté cias et que aussi il ya
fatalement des tricheries qui vont se
produire et ça donne ce résultat 50,6 %
pour jean françois copé qui se proclame
vainqueur de cette bataille électorale
alors même que il manquait encore des
résultats nous avons remonté tous les
résultats
ces résultats me donnent une courte
victoire
j'ai été élu aujourd'hui par une
majorité de militants ump
je crois qu'il serait vraiment très
opportun que françois fillon maintenant
veut bien accepter de reconnaître qu'il
n'est pas majoritaire ouais j'ai suivi
là
cette guerre copé fillon avec cette
soirée surréaliste où finalement on a
l'impression que c'est une soirée qui
n'en finit plus c'est la première fois
que il ya les chaînes d'info qui joue
aussi ce rôle parce que cette guerre se
passe en direct devant les français et
donc c'est assez surréaliste parce que
chaque camp revendique la victoire
les informations sont assez bouyer
center de psychodrame qui n'en finit pas
et il est très difficile à 100 la de
savoir qui l'emportait de savoir qui dit
la vérité
il appartient donc à monsieur fillon
s'il le souhaite de faire à ce moment là
ce recours est alors seront réexaminées
non la totalité des des bureaux de vote
pas simplement tel ou tel en fonction du
choix de monsieur fillon la totalité des
bureaux de vote
je demande à jean françois copé une
nouvelle élection par les adhérents dans
les trois mois sous le contrôle d'une
commission indépendante
le psychodrame qui se déroule à partir
du moment où l'élection est contestée
jusqu'au mois de janvier est très très
dur pour le parti et un moment où
françois fillon envisage de créer un
nouveau parti de casser au fond ump
laurent wauquiez à l'époque qui est dans
l'est dans son équipe lui conseille
vivement ils sont plusieurs à vouloir
qu'il ne fasse finalement il renonce
pour protéger la famille politique au
fond dit facettes en tout cas son
argument d'autres disent qu'il n'a pas
eu le courage de le faire
l'ump n'explose pas encore en tant que
tel mais la réalité c'est qu'il va y
avoir deux camps rivaux qui pendant cinq
ans vont faire la guerre on est dans un
moment très très dur de crise
en fond de luttes d'ambition politique
on n'est vraiment pas de souder des
décalages de lignes qui sont en fait
secondaire
finalement une instance spéciale de
l'ump intervient pour désigner un seul
et unique vainqueur
il s'agit de la coco ont obtenu jean
françois copé 50,03 % et françois fillon
49,97 % jean françois copé prend alors
la tête du parti
mais cette élection sera dévastatrice
pour l'avenir ben en fait la gare copé
fillon a laissé des traces et presque
jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire
la droite le paye encore cet épisode
parce que à partir du moment où la
victoire est accordée à jean françois
copé il ya quand même un certain nombre
d'élus et de militants qui ne
reconnaissent pas comme le chef légitime
et incontesté dès le départ il reste en
germe certaines divisions françois
fillon revendique à un moment la volonté
de faire un autre groupe à l'assemblée
nationale donc on a au sein d'une même
famille deux parties qui ne se parlent
plus et qui ne se reconnaissent plus
comme légitime
[Musique]
mais le retour de sarkozy il est inscrit
d'abord dans son adn
aujourd'hui on peut vraiment dire que la
primaire est la raison de l'échec de la
droite à la présidentielle il ya
toujours des couches de division qui
s'empilent les unes après
[Musique]